we got some new merch made but it's only
exclusive for our petrie honors
so if you go on our patreon we got some
new tiers we got the coffee mug tear
and the hoodie tier and if you're
defibrillator you get
both so make sure you go to patreon
check that out and thank you guys so
much for supporting and enjoy the video
[Music]
do you guys believe that students should
have homework
like that's like part of education they
just should just go home with homework
[ __ ] no teachers discipline kinda i
hated homework as a child
and i'm gonna hate homework as an adult
because i don't wanna [ __ ] help my
kids out with that [ __ ]
it does fall back on you unless you're
part of an after school program which we
did and we
it just it saved us well that is a good
option i might do that
yeah i don't know part of me kind of
likes it though because
in the real world you're gonna have like
deadlines and projects and things that
are due
so like like steve was saying it does
teach you discipline and like
you know time management and all that
[ __ ] and it is [ __ ] boring
thank god for homework because if not
for homework i wouldn't be good at
deadlines if i got a deadline i will hit
it every [ __ ] time because of the
stress of homework
how about you you know i um i appreciate
i appreciate all that you know but i
think i'm with joe
when i say that i i don't need to be
reminded
how stupid i am by looking at my kids
homework or trying to help them because
it gets harder and harder man
yeah or i guess uh you as a student
though
well do you think it's helpful uh oh as
a student [ __ ] homework dude that was
horrible exactly
like do you think it helped you be a
better student i mean you you said
i think i just won't revenge on the next
generation i think because i had to do
that [ __ ] i just want them to have to do
it
i think it depends on the subject like
if you're like i don't know you're
[ __ ] learning
plus and minus like i think everything
you need to learn you can learn in class
and certain things like it takes
more practice like you told me you're
boxing right i was boxing for like a
year or two in the beginning
you're learning so [ __ ] fast because
you suck so bad
so bad but then once you're after about
a year like my coach is like you need to
start shadow boxing on your own time
because now the the how much it takes to
get better is that much more that much
more that much more by the time you get
to mayweather you need to train eight
hours a day just to get one percent
better
so i think like maybe from first grade
all day till
seventh grade you probably don't need
any homework maybe eighth ninth you get
a little bit maybe your senior year you
get a little bit more
but i don't really think you need that
much homework based off what you're
learning
i take it back completely i have another
theory
okay i think that we should set up
children to uh have the right mindset
toward working and then present them the
homework and everything
because we're just kind of giving it and
told to just do it right kind of like
what bart's saying the older you are the
more homework you get
well the harder the concept is our
approach to work
all like i think the masses like most of
us that went through the school system
the the why isn't really strong right so
we just kind of go
in and we're just supposed to do this
[ __ ] but then
that work ethic gets continued on
past college and into the workplace and
you just approach everything in this way
where you half-ass it you do it last
minute just turning [ __ ] in
you turn into a human being that doesn't
take pride into their work or they're
not
like you don't really do your [ __ ] right
you just kind of like [ __ ] around
and then you approach it with resistance
because you get very used to doing
things because you have to and you
[ __ ] hate it and you're just like
torturing yourself and then you get it
over with versus
if you understand the purpose behind
something then you want to learn and you
love doing it and you want to just
murder it
some kids figure it out or they have the
parents that teach them right
so then they can they can build this i
guess in the way where it's it's a more
a better relationship with education
whereas for me
i didn't go that route so i i i found my
love for education in college and then
after that on my own
like reading the things that i want to
and when you obsess over things like
that
i think it's way better yeah i think
you're right because when isaac was a
lot younger
and he just hated homework he hated
corrections he hated being wrong
on something that he did but then over
time and then him going to the tutoring
place afterwards like he he was able to
figure out
that homework was a good thing or like
his work
was a good thing and it benefited him a
lot to the point where now that we're
doing distance learning
this fool has straight a pluses
that's amazing and he's always like on
top of his homework too like he's so
like wow he's really really good with
his
work ethic because i if i liked
something i made homework for myself
because it's not work it's just like i
like this subject so i'm gonna go ahead
and read more [ __ ] about it
yeah but then i think the reason why he
he ended up
being better with his work ethic is
because casey and i were constantly
drilling him like i would tell him all
the time i'm like dude
don't make the same mistakes i did i was
always half-assing my wife
don't be like mom don't be like yeah
it's just like don't like learn from my
mistakes and be better
and i think that worked like telling him
the why really worked
i don't it's just so hard for me to be
interested in things that i
needed to be interested in you know i
like if i had a test on
like roswell and the crash in 1947 in
july like i'd aced that [ __ ] test but
i'm like can i write an essay about it
don't get steve harney i will do my
oral presentation and turn in a
powerpoint to go along with it
but you know i do agree that homework is
important i mean if i didn't have
homework as a
as a young teenager i think i would have
masturbated myself to death
i did exactly that well you masturbated
yourself to near death
but you're you were saved homework saved
your life
yeah all right well uh there's this
teacher here
miss white and she went
kind of viral on tick tock for one of
her tick tocks and i will play it
for you oh i love tick tock so there's
two that i'm going to show you this is
the first one
tick-tock you don't stop so it says
uh in quotations you must be that
teacher that doesn't assign homework
and then
i love the teachers that didn't assign
homework right so she's one of those
teachers and then she just got
like she like i said she kind of went
viral so she just got a [ __ ] ton of
comments and this was her response
after the comments here we go
all right i'm getting a lot of comments
like this and a lot of people coming at
me
the comment says isn't homework practice
to make sure they're actually learning
okay your teachers for saying that i'm
not doing my job because i'm not
assigning homework
but there's no proof that homework is
going to make them better students in my
class
i respect their time outside of class
they work hard for me all day they don't
need to go home and do more homework
because if they do it at home it does
not show me mastery
it's extra practice sure but not
practice if they're doing it wrong
it's not good practice if they're
cheating it's not good practice if
they're having someone else do it
most of my students are high schoolers
they have jobs
they have ffa they have sports they're
in practice they're in band
they have other responsibilities outside
of school some of them are going home
and taking care of their younger
siblings because their parents are at
work
some of them just need to go home and
sleep some of them have to go home and
worry about how they're going to eat
because there's no food at their house
so if i also
give them hours of homework when do they
have time to be kids
when do they have time to relax because
when you get off of work
you want to go home and relax so i'm a
good teacher and i'm doing much
that's dope she's like by the way i
teach space trigonometry
also who's this message for no parent i
know is on tick tock
this is she's just she's talking to kids
at this point
well i guess a lot of other teachers
were talking [ __ ]
no she says that um it sounded like a
lot of these comments were coming from
people who aren't
educators of course not non-experts
well maybe it's parents that are like
man my kids are [ __ ] annoying keep
them occupied please
hmm i i like it i like her point and i
like because i have friends who have
kids and they seem to be
um stressed out having to help their
kids with the homework
yes more than the kids do sometimes yes
and like when your kid
springs on you sunday night like oh yeah
i have like a science project due
monday yeah tell me do you have a mom do
you have one of those
trifold poster boards just laying around
that was me bro yeah then you're making
a trip to you know long's drugs at uh
you know 11 p.m oh my god is that still
around no
thrifties
we had to do a science project when i
was in like fourth grade
and i'll never forget telling my dad i
was like yeah we have to build a robot
so i think i'm just gonna put a trash
can on top of a
rc car and then i'll be able to drive my
robot around right
and he's like oh no no no son i can help
you with this so he took me like
radio shack and he i just basically sat
there bored while my dad
like happily built a robot and like he
built it
like partly partially out of legos and
used rubber bands to make treads on tire
like on gears move and [ __ ] and so i
presented it the next day and it was
like a little robot that
would beep and go across the floor and
it spun like a mop
like wow on both hands yeah my dad's
very smart
and then the teacher's like you built
that and i was like
yeah like i did not build this [ __ ]
thing you're still trying to learn how
to use it
yeah i was like i was just falling
asleep at the table while my dad's
building it and like not
built the first roomba you did actually
uh yeah case and i are kind of guilty a
bit too from like taking over because we
got excited
she got excited it's fun huh cause isaac
had to create this like
uh this the hollywood sign
on like the mountain and [ __ ] out of
people that already sounds cool as [ __ ]
yeah it came out so dope and uh but
isaac like he got to paint a lot of this
stuff he did help with the paper mache
[ __ ] but like
honestly kids suck at [ __ ] but honestly
casey neistat most of it well and their
motor skills are still kind of shaky and
like they're not as developed fourth
grade too
so when you got all his a pluses you're
like yeah i think one of those belongs
to me
no that's why i'm so proud of him right
now he doesn't have
any help like at all like he doesn't ask
us for any homework help he doesn't have
that after school program he used to go
to
it's 100 on him and he's been killing it
sounds like he's sleeping with the
teacher
yeah it's a little more complicated but
possible
it is possible oh jesus but then i kind
of worry because i'm like [ __ ] i kind of
don't want him to go back to the
classroom then because then
he's a really social kid and i think
that's why that's why he didn't get
as good grades before because he gets
distracted he's the one that's talking
to friends and
always had that on my report card too
talkative it talks too much in class
yeah same here look where we are i mean
i'm still talking still [ __ ] talking
too talkative i wish i had recordings of
myself um you know like from elementary
school
no that's so true because you're just
going based off a memory but i'm like
man i can't watch recordings of myself
now so i'm good
i'd like to think that you would be a
business version of the person i'm
looking at right now just like clean
haircut you know suit and die
comb over something happen along the
lines something happened up here yep
i don't know i think maybe
you're right i always like uh the
quickest
way to learning things and i don't know
if homework at home
is the way to do it like some of my best
teachers like
i felt like i learned so much in such a
short amount of time
that we didn't even feel like we needed
homework so i feel like
yeah you're right because some of the
teachers that didn't give out homework
their lectures were so [ __ ] good that
you wanted to keep going back
and just listening to them yeah where
did you guys go to school bro
no it's like one or one or two teachers
and i was like yeah there's a couple of
gems here and there yeah
every four years or some [ __ ] yeah the
best teachers were the ones that
listened
the best teachers were the ones that
didn't do [ __ ]
and it was a rainy day every day and you
watch terminators oh you just like
the tv get rolled in that was [ __ ]
dude i didn't learn [ __ ] but that was
tight i was the best
[Music]
you